track
[Music]
I got something to say about May's local
elections tdoc spit in bars about boat
ID selection so make sure you bring it
or you'll receive rejections
so may call it suppression but don't be
a square it's about making sure this
election is fair your passport your
driving license you get the gist hop
online to see the full extensive list
make sure your vote counts so bring your
ID looks like this card with a little
photo of me if you haven't got this
identification apply online for your
photo authorities certification yeah
come on guys the message is clear May's
local election is Drawing Near bring
your ID to make your vote count this is
what democracy is all about perfect